Hi everyone
In this video, we will be talking about two
topics of 3D chapter for
mathematics of JEE preparation.
The topics are: doing problems on finding
perpendicular distance of a point from line
and we will be finding equations of a line
perpendicular to two lines given.
These are small topics but as in other maths
topics, you should learn the approach to solve
problems like these.
Let us start by finding perpendicular distance
of a point from a line.
We have a line given.
Let us saw we have point A, and that is a_vector,
and we have been given b_vector, which is
the parallel vector.
And we have been given a point P. Let us call
it p_vector.
And we have been asked to find the perpendicular
distance of the point from the line.
You may recall these kind of problems in 2D
in straight lines.
But now its 3D or 3-Dimensinal Geometry.
So how will we solve this problem?
One of the approaches to start this to think
that there is a point C here, let us call
it c_vector.
And the idea is that we know,
c_vector=a_vector + \lambda b_vector
because this point is on the line.
And, PC_vector is perpendicular to b_vector.
This is what we know, right?
These are the two conditions we know for the
PC_vector to be perpendicular to the parallel
vector because this is perpendicular to the
line, so it has to be perpendicular to the
parallel vector.
It should flash to you that the condition
of perpendicularity it PC_vector \dot b_vector
= 0.
Again, the knowledge of vectors is super critical
in this chapter.
I have emphasized that many times in the last
two videos also.
PC_vector is nothing but c_vector - p_vector.
Thus, c_vector-p_vector \dot b_vector = 0.
And c_vector is nothing but (a_vector + \lambda
b_vector - p_vector) \dot b =0.
If you were to find the value of \lambda,
you will get, \lambda = ( (p_vector - a_vector)
\dot b_vector, divided by |b|^2.
Now you have got the value of \lambda, so you can calculate the point, and then you can calculate the distance.
I hope you are able to understand and follow
what we are doing here. You can solve this
equation using the associative property by
opening the brackets, and rearranging, you get this.
Let us do a problem on this so that you can
quickly understand.
You have been given P=(1,2,3). And the line
is (x-6)/3 = (y-7)/2 = (z-7)/(-2).
How will we find \lambda? I will suggest
you to remember this but you may want to derive it in the paper.
It is up to you. I will recommend
you to remember this, it is
very easy to remember ( (p_vector - a_vector)
\dot b_vector ) / |b_vector|^2.
Here,
p_vector = i_cap + 2j_cap+ 3k_cap
a_vector = 6i_cap + 7j_cap+ 7k_cap
b_vector = 3i_cap + 2j_cap - 2k_cap
If I were to find \lambda here, this would
become
p_vector - a_vector is -5i - 5j - 4k \dot
with 3i + 2j -2k
( (p_vector - a_vector) \dot b_vector ) / |b_vector|^2.
|b_vector|^2 = 3^2 + 2^2 + 2^2 = 8 + 9 = 17.
If you will do this, this will become: -15-10+8
= -17.
Thus \lambda = -1.
The point c_vector = a_vector - b_vector,
and it comes out to be, 3i_cap + 5j_cap +
9k_cap.
And the distance |PC| = (2^2+3^2+6^2)^(1/2)
= 7.
You know the vector PC now, so you can find
the distance by taking the sum of x_component^2,
y_component^2 and z_component^2, and that
comes out to be 7.
And I hope that is very obvious for you to
solve these types of problems. If you are
still not very comfortable, please practice.
Just make some problems yourself, make an
equation of a line, find a point, and then
do the problem. It is very easy. If you do
this several times, it should be quick for
you to remember.
Let me give you one more HW problem so that
you can do it on your own. And the HW problem
is:
Find a point on y_axis such that
perpendicular distance from the point to line
x=y=z is unity.
So this is an opposite question. You have
been given the task to find the point on y-axis
such that the perpendicular distance from
the line to the point is unity. So, how will
you do this problem?
You can assume a point: (0, k, 0), and proceed
now, completely the same way. You can very
quickly find the value of this thing (\lambda),
and then you can calculate PC, and you can
equate it to 1, to find the value of k.
Please do this problem. This will give you
a nice practice to solve the problems of perpendicular
distance of a point from a line.
Let us do another problem which I wanted to
do. I will not be giving you any method, I
just want to do an example problem since that
example will be enough to understand the topic.
The question says we have been given two lines:
(x-1)/1 = (y-2)/2 = (z-3)/3, L1 is this
L2 has been given as (x-2)/4 = (y-3)/5 = (z-1)/6.
The
question says find the line
perpendicular to L1 and L2 and passing through
1,1,1. How to solve this problem?
So you have been given line L1. Let me write
answer here:
Let us say this is L1 and this is L2. You
have been given a1_vector, b1_vector, a2_vector,
b2_vector. You have been asked to find line
3 for which you know that it is perpendicular
to both, and it passes through the point.
To find the equation of line, you need a point,
which you already have, and you need a parallel
vector. What is speciality of parallel vector?
That the line is perpendicular to line L1
and L2. Hence, the parallel vector will be
perpendicular to both b1 and b2.
And as soon as I say this, it should flash
into your mind, that this is basically asking
you to take a cross product. Thats it.
If you cannot recall this, please become more
thorough with understanding the physical meaning
of dot product and cross product. We have
discussed here dot product: perpendicularity
condition of dot product already. We have
done in the last video, that dot product is
used for finding angles. So as soon as I say,
it should come to your mind, the vector perpendicular
to two vectors is the cross product of two
vectors.
So what you have to do is that you have to
find b3_vector = b1 \cross b2, and if you
do, you should remember that for cross product
you have to do this i, j, k — and opening
up the determinant.
So if you do that, this will be: i(-3) + j(6)
+ k(-3). Is this perpendicular to b1 and b2?
You should remember that condition of perpendicularity
is dot product is zero.
So if you take -3 + 12 - 9, that is dotted
with b1, it comes out to be 0.
If you dot with b2, -12 + 30 -18, so 30 - 30
= 0. So it is perpendicular to both b1 and
b2.
And you already have point.
So the equation of line L3 could be easily
written as: (x-1)/3 = (y-1)/6 = (z-1)/(-3).
This line is perpendicular to both the lines
and passes through (1,1,1).
I hope that you are able to understand this,
understand how important the understanding
of vectors is, and how to solve the problems.
We discussed two things here: how to find
the perpendicular distance of a point from
a line. For that, we can remember this formula
of \lambda. Calculate \lambda, calculate the
point, and when you get the coordinates of
the point, you subtract from the original
point to get the distance. I have given you
a homework problem, so please do that at home.
And then we did a problem of finding a line
perpendicular to two lines. For that you are
taking the cross product of the parallel vectors,
and then you will get the equation of the
line.
I hope you enjoyed this video. There are a
lot more interesting videos and topics in
this chapter. So I hope to see you in the
next video. Thank you.